hello in this video we'll talk about
graft rejection
this terminology might not be new for
you you have heard it multiple times
that skin graft
is rejected and it's also known from
ancient time that grafting was pretty
common
but in this video we'll talk about the
immunological
basis of craft rejection
so graft rejection is a common phenomena
but tissue grafting is a very important
surgical process
imagine you have a third degree burn in
your hand
and a graft from other places of your
body
can repair the skin or replace the skin
in that burned area
right so that is why it's a nice process
but there is a risk associated with this
process there could be rejection of
graft and our goal is to learn why
grafts
could be rejected
so here is an example of a burn site
one possibility is the graft
would be appropriate it won't be
rejected
and it would be it is accepted by the
recipient right so healing
after grafting there could be other
possibility as well
that it didn't heal and the graft is
rejected and necrosis happened in that
region
so in this video we'll question why
sometimes graft is rejected and why
sometimes graft could be accepted
so let's look at rejection of craft in
few
and ask few questions first of all we'll
ask
why the graft is rejected what are the
key cellular players
that mediates the graft rejection
process then what is the time skill
of graft rejection before that let us
familiarize with few terms such as
autograft
autograft is a self tissue that is
transferred from one location of your
body to the other location
let's say you have a burn site in your
hand so from your leg a portion of
skin is taken and grafted on your hand
so this kind of situation is an example
of autograft then isograft
means that transferring of this graph
between genetically identical
individuals
for example monozygotic tweens
or identical twins right then let's talk
about
allograft it is a situation
where the graft is transferred
between two members of the same species
but their genetic makeup
might be different and here is the
chance of rejection
right the chances of rejection of
allograft is pretty high
unless and until certain criterias are
matched
we'll learn about that lastly the
extreme most situation
xenograft that is a situation
when a craft is obtained from a
different species altogether
and grafted to an individual now
let us take a specific example right
let's say a portion of our skin is
burned
and we need to graft a skin tissue to
repair it
so autograft is uh
given to that particular burn site and
let's see what happens
so once the autograph is given
there could be revascularization just
underneath
that damaged site there could be some
amount of immune cells creating a little
bit of inflammation in that area but
over time in a course of seven to ten
days
that portion would be healed and now you
cannot
like distinguish between the burned area
versus the healed area right
and ultimately it would be resolved in a
span of two weeks
now let's talk about talk about a
allograft
now in this allograft similarly there
would be vascularization phase
a lot of immune cells would be moving
out of this vascular
vascularized region and they would mount
an immune response against that
graft there would be cellular
infiltration there would be intense
inflammation ultimately this might
lead to huge amount of cytokine or
inflammatory cytokine secretion in that
region
a combination of all these factors would
ultimately
create huge inflammatory response which
might lead to a necrosis in that region
so thrombosis and necrosis can occur
in this particular region and ultimately
what we would
see from outside that this graft is
rejected
this also happens in a time course of 10
to 14 days
now let me tell you there could be two
type of
graft rejection rejection first set
graph rejection which kind of takes
14 to 15 days and the second set
rejection which is quicker
and it only takes 10 days to reject the
second set of craft
like you have rejection of one graph and
you again grafted
this in the same location how fast that
graph would be rejected is shown
here now let's talk about what are the
key cell types
that are behind graph rejection
and the answer comes from classical
experiments
here is a strain of mouse which is known
as a naive strain
right so first screen graft would be
given to this particular
strain b from a mouse strain a
so the graft is introduced to mouse
strain b
so there would be first set of rejection
possibly right
if the graft is doesn't graft is not
matching and the immune system of this
mouse is considering it to be
alien species or a kind of like a
foreign substance right
and that happens in a course of 14 days
as we have learned
then there could be a second set of
grafting and that would be rejected
in a time span of a further 10 days
right now if
particular cell types such as t cells
are taken from a first set rejection
mice and injected to a naive strain
then it shows a kinetics which is very
similar to a second set rejection
right so after putting the prime
t cells in the strain b
mouse and then grafting the tissue leads
to a second set rejection
the kinetics became faster that tells us
in turn t cells or t helper cells
might have a role in terms of craft
rejection
there is another set of experiment which
tells this phenomena
in a more confirmative way so there are
four set of mouse
and we have given graphs now along with
graphs
in set two three and four we have given
specific antibodies such as antiseriate
antibodies to neutralize the cd8
t cell population then in the set 3 we
have given anti cd4
and anti cd4 to neutralize the
t helper cells and lastly we give a
combination of anti-cd4 and ndcda
and let's look at the survival of the
graft in each of these cases
we see this kind of graph when we have
blocked both cd4 positive and cd8
positive t
cells the graft's survival time
is very high compared to singly blocking
any of these type of t cells this
experiment tells us
that t cell is a key player behind this
graph
rejection phenomena now let us let us
talk about two phases of graph rejection
one is a sensitization phase these are
cellular events that we are talking
about right now
and then the second is the effector
phase in the sensitization phase
the graft is recognized as foreign
substance and in the effector phase
necrosis or damage happens
so here is the graft which would have
dendritic cells macrophages etc in that
graft
and it is showing or displaying the
antigens that is present
in those graft and that can be treated
as foreign by the t cells
present in the recipient
so dendritic cell expresses
specific molecules known as class 2 mhc
if you want to learn
details you can click the link in the
description or in the
i button now t helper cells would get
activated once t cell t helper cells are
activated
from the macro by the macrophages coming
from these graft
tissue then it can secrete various
cytokines
such as il2 il 6 etc
and all of these cytokines in turns
activates
different type of cell population such
as cd8 cytotoxic
cell population b cells or dth cells
now there are multiple responses that
can happen for example
dth cells can secrete interferon gamma
that might activate macrophages an
active macrophage secretes several lytic
enzymes which can damage the tissue
c8 positive cytotoxic t cells can
secrete
perforin and granzyme to lyse the tissue
also there could be antibody mediated
response
antibody might determine specific
epitopes on this grafted tissue
and there could be antibody dependent
cytotoxic response
mediated by natural killer cell
or other cell types a combination of all
this cellular mechanism
leads to apoptosis or huge amount of
necrosis in that particular
grafted region and that leads to
graft rejection so what we have learned
so far is the cellular mechanism
mechanism but in order to prevent graft
rejection
there are specific precautions which are
taken
and first and foremost thing is hla
typing
so mhc molecules are key player in terms
of
the sensitization phase of the graph
rejection so hlf typing is done
before transplantation in a different
video we'll talk more about the hla
antigens and hlr typing so stay tuned
and watch more videos from this channel
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and you can use my code epi 10 to get a
10 discount
in academy lectures so subscribe now you
can also support my channel
in patreon and thank you for listening
see you in the next video